[Applause]
take care everyone i'm Radloff i'm
coming from sofia bulgaria all the way
to Switzerland and this is my third year
of Python and also this is my third time
speaking at your Python and I'm really
happy and I'm really grateful for having
this opportunity so thanks for having me
and I hope this will be a good talk for
you go of this talk as always I want to
be really practical really pragmatic and
I want to provide value for you so
you'll have 40 minutes spent really well
here in this room and actually the thing
that I'm looking for is this aha moment
let's use this from this guy's talk from
this very particular slide so this is my
angle if at least a couple of people
have this aha moment and I'm going to be
happy because I have provided value for
for someone so context I'm the CEO of
hack soft this is a software development
company and we develop software for our
clients and we usually our clients rely
with their businesses on the software
that we develop we develop this software
in teams of course and in order to have
a stable software and happy clients we
need to have a pretty good teams we need
to have productive teams that can ship
quality software and not break
production every day you know this is
very important because otherwise clients
are losing money and this is hard to say
it's very important thing the I will
provide some terrific examples from the
last six years from being a team leader
on several different teams and I hope
this will be valuable for you the agenda
will jump straight into the topic I will
talk a little bit more about the team
leaders perspective for me as a team
leader what I care for and what I opt
amaizing
this I'm going to talk a little bit
about software development and what kind
of problems we can have there and how
can we solve those problems after this
we're going to talk about features
because after all we create new features
for our clients and in the end we're
going to finish in a pythonic way with a
section called explicit is better than
implicit because after all we are at
your beta so team leaders perspective
aside from being the CEO of the company
my day-to-day job involves developing
with Python with Django and with
JavaScript and I'm team lead of several
teams at the company working for
different clients so I've developed this
perspective because at some points I
said to myself okay I have a team things
are going well but I have no formal
education for this and I have no idea
how I'm actually running the team I have
two formalized I have to write this down
because if I want to transfer if I want
to transfer my knowledge to someone else
then I really can't do it because it's
all in my head so those are kind of the
seven things that I care for and that I
optimize for when I'm running a team and
this is what we're going to cover like
we are going to have problems that
impact on those seven teams and we're
going to try to solve those problems so
first of all productivity this is very
important we have to ship software to
the clients we have to have something
working used by end-users being on
production you know I think we can all
agree this is very product this is very
important we need to ship software so
first of all productivity second of all
I want my team to ship features with
confidence because if we have a pretty
unstable production and I believe you've
seen this people will be hesitant to
merge poor requests and to deploy to
production because they know they have
to fix other things regressions you know
constant regressions and we want to
eliminate this we want to have higher
confidence because this will make the
team better and they will enjoy the work
they do also we want to have
independence in the team as a team lead
I don't want to be the bottleneck of
everyone everyone asking me questions
all right or should I do this or should
I do that oh I don't know figure it out
run several tests and you can your
can pick the better solutions this is
quite important we want our team to be
as independent as possible also
well-being if you're working on a
stressful project and you're stressing
your team like more than needed they
will burn out and when your team team
burns out then you as a team leader you
are also going to burn out and when you
as a team leader burns out then the
software is going to burn down software
doesn't burn out it burns down
everything is going to crash so this is
quite important to have a healthy team
because if you push it in too far
everything will eventually crash because
software is created by humans and humans
need to be in ok state to do this also
something very important for me less
context switching being a developer it's
very important being this flow state we
all know the flow state we're working on
something we are in it we are wired in a
couple days in a feature and we're
feeling pretty good and suddenly people
start asking us different questions on
topics that are not related with what we
do and if this is happening constantly
then we'll be constantly breaking
people's flow which means there will be
less productive less happy and this will
increase the stress level so my
philosophy for context switching is that
the team leader should handle most of
the context switches this is part of the
job and that's why it's it's a hard job
and you should reduce the context
switches between in the team there will
be some of course and but you should try
to reduce them because then people will
be productive and they will carry on the
tasks they have to do also someone being
blocked this is my favorite you know you
have a team of five two people are
working like crazy the other three are
just what should we do you have a task
but we are waiting for the client have
you ask questions no and stuff like this
you know you have to observe people
being blocked and not working you have
to make sure everyone has a good
knowledge and what they are working on
and there
nothing blocking them or if something
blocking them resolve it immediately
otherwise there will be people working
like crazy people just idling around
making coffee and of course the last
thing which is really hard to quantify
but it's the team route you know this is
the general feeling of the team are you
going to work every day and you feel the
team is like there are better things
that we can do especially that right now
it's summer in Bulgaria or the team is
like we're shipping something quite
interesting users are going to use it we
want to do this we kind of enjoy we find
meaning in what we do we kind of enjoy
our job so this is something that is
again really hard to quantify but as a
team mate you can get a feeling of the
team around and it's really important to
keep that up so I will go one by one
cherry-picked examples going for the aha
moment this makes sense and I guess
we'll have questions we'll have time for
Q&A at the end and the first thing that
usually happens when we're developing
software in a team environment and it's
a low-hanging fruit are the constant
regressions you know constant
regressions what do I mean by that this
is production going down every hour
every day something breaking you you you
create a new feature that breaks several
other features and the reason for that
most often is because you have a client
and the client says alright let's do a
quick proof of concept for two weeks we
just want to see if this is viable you
do the quick proof of concept of course
and then the client is happy and without
telling you the client is now onboarding
on your Def environment actual users
your definite variant becomes production
environment and the client start put
start pushing you for new features or
complete rewrite of everything because
for the clients when they see something
working they want to be like new feature
changed in new feature change thing they
want to be like snap and half the
codebase changes you know this is how
clients think about software and we all
know this is not the case so usually
in constant regressions involves and as
I said this is low-hanging fruit those
things
stop all future development this is
really working you know you say to the
current alright we're stopping for I
don't know a day two days a week and we
want to stabilize things because we
cannot develop like this we need to make
make this proof of concept a proper a
production setup add some tests refactor
some of the code because we've been
cutting corners in order to make it for
the two weeks because you have a
presentation at some conference but now
let's make it stable and this if you
explain this well enough to the client
it already works also it sounds strange
but at a continuous integration and
please have tests because you may say
well every software development project
project has tests and I will say to you
know we are constantly having requests
for can you take a look at this seven
years old
Django codebase that's huge project
that's running mission-critical stuff
for the business and has zero tests oh
and the developers by the way they just
left us so we need someone to figure
this out so this is very important have
a continuous integration have tests
we'll talk about tests later and our
staging environment where you can safely
test and break without a problem and
this is fine now we have higher
confidence because we have staging we
have tests we have CI then all things
are going well you start working on
different features and this is a case
that I observe very often for example we
have even in Moorea and some other folks
working on even is working on a specific
feature Maria is working on a different
feature those features have nothing in
common and let's say we're running in a
jungle environment where have a nap and
we have our services py file where we
put our business logic and this is just
one Python module and since Eve and
Maria need to write something related to
that to the SAP which is a new feature
they're going to write it in the
services py file and because we've
started small we also have a simple test
services py module where all the tests
are for the different services and
meanwhile to spice things up
folks are fixing existing services and
guess what happens
in the two yellow boxes like constant
merge conflicts constant merge conflicts
because we're trying to after all be
productive and move fast move quickly
ship features and this can be very very
frustrating and it's easy it's very easy
to do something about it and since we're
working in a Python environment with
Python language if we have a services py
module we just make it a module that's a
folder with sub modules inside and split
by domain split by features the thing
that we try to do is to isolate
different people working on different
features in their own files this really
this gives a fact and it's a nice way to
kind of separate people not stop
stepping on their toes and diagram wise
it looks like this we just split the
services in different features we do the
same thing for the tests because I
usually see people splitting the
features but not splitting the tests and
ending up with test files with two three
four thousand lines of code that you
need to split because first it's slow in
the editor to load all of this and then
it's really hard to fix merge conflicts
that spans two different test cases for
two different things
you know sometimes get this get this
funky so with this when you see it you
can optimize it we usually do it when
it's needed we don't start with let's
create an architecture for this because
this project is going to take five years
to make we don't know this but when we
identify we are running in some merge
conflicts in some part of the code base
we try to split things around we try to
figure out abstractions so this is not
happening all right and then we continue
local setup this is a specific type of
hell and I love it if your local setup
is not OK your developers can't even
start working on their features this is
like maximum level of frustration you
have to do something this something is
required by the end of the week it's
easy you know what to do
but you can get your local environments
running and it's really really really
really frustrating so my job as a team
lead is just to sit down and make sure
everyone for example has accounts for
altered parties that we're using 0go
cardless AWS mantra whatever keys
accounts I want to know that everyone on
my team has the proper access to
whatever's needed so when they need it
and I do this before it's needed because
when they need it
it's already there and they won't be
pinging me I have to go out of context
and create this for them and the thing
that really helps is organizing keeping
a spreadsheet you know if something is
really hard to do in your in your head
if I'm running a team of two people I
don't new spreadsheet because two people
everyone has access you know but if your
team rolls bigger it's really hard to
manage it in your head and then you have
to start managing it somewhere else and
this is like a really important key
takeaway for software development for
team leadership or whatever work you
have to do if things get too big and you
cannot fit and fit them in your head and
you're going to forget about things
because this is what we do as humans we
forget just add a spreadsheet out of
Trello board something writes write this
thing down so you have it as a reference
after this and then you have accounts
for everyone but I don't know how to
start a project it's it looks like
Django but has several different flux DB
running locally on my machine it's the
first time I'm hearing about the sign
it's celery brokers to fail I don't know
how to run it and in order to unblock
your people to be able to work and to
develop oakley without problems you have
to document relentlessly and I mean
relentlessly everything should be
written down and not only written down
because what usually happens is team
lead says person X please create a
documentation because you know how to
set up everything person X creates it
but because everything's running okay on
his computer or her computer they can
miss a step
so you have to then take the
documentation test it to yourself and
give it to someone else so they can test
it and if you achieve a running clock of
environment then the documentation is
okay and actually this is I love this
because when you onboard you people to
the team this is a great test how well
structured your team is can you provide
a set of links and documents to the new
on board to the new hire so they can get
up and running within a few hours and
start actually working if you can do
this then perhaps you've done a good job
with the structure of the team and
that's why just relentlessly document I
know this is what's the word in English
for this cumbersome or not very pleasant
people don't like to document local to
document or document located but you
have to do it in order for your team to
feel better not to have I cannot run
this I cannot develop because I cannot
run this and on top of this because
we're programmers if we have a good
documentation we can then create scripts
to automate most of the setup usually in
all of our projects we have something
called bootstrap which just creates a
local environment that's ready to go and
for example if we have like an
additional zero dependency that's not
required for the majority of the system
we have script that set of zero or setup
sets up go cardless or we have a script
code everything that sets up as you can
guess everything which may take a few
minutes but you know after you run the
script it's going to say you're missing
X Y Z as dependencies or environment
variables or keys and once you do this
you're ready to go and you can start
working on your local dev with all
dependencies set up it's it's worthwhile
investing time and this because we end
up doing quite a lot of both drops quite
a lot of okay we did something let's
both sharply start clean and this is
actually help helping us a lot and next
speed of tests very important and often
overlooked imagine you're working in in
a team where you have to do small PRS
merge often and apply
and your test suite takes 10 minutes to
run on CI you're not dead 10 minutes is
liver you know it can be 15 20 and more
you won't be feeling very productive and
you know what humans adapt if you want
your team to make short commits and
commit often and also your tests take 10
minutes
they won't do short commits because
instead of doing five commits and taking
an hour I will just bunch things and do
one commit because I know tests take
awhile and this is something that is
very often overlooked but really really
really important you-you-you need this
quick feedback loop from the test it's
not a trivial problem to solve there
were plenty of good talks at your Python
about this you have to just figure it
out because people adapt and their work
style will adapt to the speed of the
tests which is strange but it happens
for me the solution of the problem was
to install pi PI test exists just say
minus M 4 and from 10 minutes it's went
to 5 minutes I felt really good because
let's try this and let's see if it's
working and it's working and after
further tests up to mutation we managed
to get it down in further and this paid
off because people now started working
in smaller commits because tests were
running faster but you have to figure it
out for your own context and minus X
means fail on the first error because
sometimes you don't want your entire
test suite running on CI if there is an
error you know it helps out optimize
your test it pays out it really pays out
it was a strange observation that people
adjust to the speed of the CI but it is
alright working with clients they
request stuff we call this stuff
features it sounds better you know
instead of I'm working on stuff I'm
working on features and features can be
a source of a lot of
problems and make sure everyone's on the
same page with this first thing that's
that can be really problematic our
feature descriptions no matter if you're
using JIRA or Journal or whatever you
like or whatever your team is using
there is usually a client or a product
owner that says let's do this
and they will either provide you a cart
with some description or let's do this
and you have to create the cart with
some description and if this description
is not correct or if you have not
understood as team lead for example what
needs to be done people will be working
on the wrong thing and after a week you
will find out when the client is testing
or the POS testing and they say hmm we
were expecting something else this is
not what we were expecting and this this
can be quite detrimental to the team
morale and to the productivity because
you just do work that's going to be
undone and redone again and sadly the
sometimes it happens sometimes you do
something that's not going to make it
but if you do this for every feature
it's bad and the thing that I usually
try to do is to ask a lot of questions
that's why clients don't like me very
much because I ask a lot of questions
and they have to think and they have to
answer those questions but once this is
ready and we know what we are actually
doing first we may save some
over-engineering that's not needed
currently because when the client says I
want something we as programmers start
to expand and inflate and cover all the
cases and make it backwards compatible
and make it production already for
millions of users you know business is
usual for us but after some question
after some talking you can scope down
the feature you can write it you can
create diagrams and you can leave it in
a good state because then you don't have
to repeat the entire conversation it's
like can you please read the cart and
say something that's not ok according to
you to the client
then you can safely give this card to to
the to the team to the developers and
another very important thing make sure
they read the entire cart because you've
just spent an hour or two writing down a
good description creating diagrams then
a developer takes the card reads it
diagonally and still create something
else
and still there's work to be undone and
stuff like this so it's very important
to have some kind of planning don't
overdo it but some kind of planning so
everyone's on the same page at least at
least from my experience this is very
important
saves a lot of headaches and you will
not have all the negative impacts of
work being undone so Yvonne and Maria
they are briefed there they know what
needs to be done for for two specific
features and they start working on those
features you know but feature a feature
B although different they rely on common
piece of software that can be either
there or yet to be implemented and again
since we're working in team we have to
synchronize this because what can happen
if Anna Maria if for example this common
piece of abstraction is not implemented
they will implement it themselves and
after this we have to undo some of the
worker all of the work because they
haven't synchronized between them that
they need this common piece of software
or there can be abstraction and even
adjust the abstraction for his needs
Maria does the same thing for hers knee
for her needs and in the end we have fun
compatible abstraction in the middle and
this happens quite often and the way to
solve it is to first identify it and
then have them pair on the common part
so they're on the same page they know
their requirements they know that this
abstraction is going to make it to be
okay for both features or create the
abstraction so it's okay for both
features and they're then they're going
to do their job and you won't be undoing
work again and doing work can be very
detrimental to the team morale we kind
of attach ourselves to the cold
emotionally and when this cult is
deleted people take it negatively like
they've done something bad and sometimes
it's not like this so this very
important make makeup may cause
conflicts all right okay
I'm okay with the time can slow down a
bit and those were some cherry-picked
examples from you know day to day
software development and how to solve
problems that are happening quite
regularly and to keep your team happy
and keep hurting productive and now the
part that I call explicit is better than
implicit because we're at the Python
conference this is this is a favorite
scenario there's a bug you know sentry
error in a slack channel we have a team
of four there are happily developing
features communicating everything's fine
but suddenly there is a sensor and what
usually happens is that the sensory
error loves attention and it gets the
attention from all the developers
because there's notification in a
channel that's dedicated to century
errors and what usually happens everyone
starts looking at the error
everyone starts running some shell to
check things around everyone starts
looking at the code if they synchronize
someone will make a fix if they don't
seem from nice several people can make a
fix then they have to synchronize which
fix should go to production two hours
have passed and it's lunchtime and you
know this is at least for me a really
bad way to break the flow of your entire
team you have four peoples and suddenly
you have one people one people one
person who's four people acting like one
to fix a century error and if this
happens once a week it's okay it's
bearable you know it may be a really bad
production error that requires the
attention of everyone but if this is
like a really small error that's quite
easy to fix it's bad to break the flow
off your entire team and this is team of
four it can happen the same for team of
seven you know because if there's an
error and pee
Oh care about the project because if you
have a team that does not care about the
project then nobody will break rotation
but nobody will fix their which is also
bad this is for me this is quite bad and
it was happening happening quite often
it's at different teams so we decided to
do something that's you know like a
standard approach have a dedicated
explicit firefighter for the wake this
is the developer who's going to be the
first responder to one or many like a
team it depends on your skill this is
going to be the first responder to to an
error nobody else looks at the error
because they know there's someone
explicitly dedicated this week to fixers
and only if the error requires the
attention of someone else damping then
take the attention of the other people
and this helps a lot this increase the
productivity and increase and reduce
this panicking times where oh there's
their order sir
and everyone's running around
contributing you know making it seems
seem worse than it is and this explicit
firefighter you rotate it every week so
everyone goes on that duty and it's it
works really well
and while we are explicitness there's
one more team rotation after this while
with explicitness something that's again
a low-hanging fruit but I've seen
problems with this your team should know
very well the way that you're working
with git and github because I've seen
teams where several people are using it
flow it several people are using github
flow on the same project and they're
happy but it's not compatible inside the
same project so make sure you have
written explicit rules for how you use
github this is the flow that we use this
is how we do pour requests you can have
poor request and play it's issue
templates all the good stuff that's
provided for example from github and
perhaps bit bit bucket and get lap so
everyone's on the same page for how
you're using git and how you're using
otherwise they're going to be chaos my
fixes are in develop what's developed
with merging master you know so no
matter what you use is really important
to have this those lights should have
been before the parasite but Norris and
another thing that I've observed any
pace of really well is to separate
refactoring from future development
especially on big big projects because
sometimes you want to do a small bit of
refactoring and also introduced a
feature with this and what happens when
you do this is you have a very
unreadable pour request because you may
hide new feature or new functionality in
the refactoring diff because the diff is
going to be this was removed this was
added but it's not the same removing the
same edit with different name we have
two more lines in the middle and people
can overlook this at poor request
reviews and those two lines can actually
break so it's really hard to read and
the other thing is if this pork was
breaks something now we don't know was
it the refactoring was it the new
feature was it the combination of both
things so refactoring should be just
refactoring and then after this make a
new feature poor request because it's
going to be much easier to read mostly
new lines you don't have poor requests
very have 200 new lines 200 removed
lines and it's beautiful you know red
and green but it's really hard to really
have treat and why we're at the explicit
thing writing down how you do pull
requests and writing down how you how
you do you know refactoring PRS versus
feature pairs it's a good idea to have
something that we call team rose to
write everything that's implicitly known
in the team down everything that this is
how we do things here because when you
go to a new team and you ask why is this
like that and someone answers this is
how we've always done it it's a good
idea to sit and write down all those in
place
ruse and make them is explicit and have
them at one place because first you can
spot strange things that are no longer
valid and you can fix them
second everyone on the team can be on
the same page you kind of establish a
framework for everyone and you say if
you want to be on the team this is the
framework that we follow you know this
is how we do things in the steel it may
not be optimal for every case but this
is how we do things here this is very
important for people for coherent teams
to have coherent teams and also again
onboarding new people this is great
because when you Albert a new person and
everything's implicit in the team this
new person has to navigate those
implicit rules ask questions understand
from observations
Wow it's much better to provide him a
document or her document and say you
know this is the team though this is the
framework of the team read it ask
questions if something's not clear
enough and let's go with it so very
important and actually yields good
benefits those team rules again make it
make it explicit instead of implicit and
while we are at the explicit and
implicit that something else that we've
observed then it's very important at Lee
at least for me have an explicit leader
you know there are teams with flat
structure and there's an implicit leader
there's this person that everyone
listens to and everyone kind of knows
that's the person that makes the final
decisions and it's again a good idea as
everything else to make this person
explicit to say this is the team lead he
yields he's responsive if something goes
wrong he is responsible know the leader
is responsible for this and he also or
she also makes the final decision if
there are people arguing then the team
that makes the final decision and it's
really good to have this otherwise
there's going to be implicit one and
politics will be involved sadly and
again know who the leader is
and something that I was leading a team
at hack soft and then I gave this team
to someone else who's now coming who's
now the new team lead and he did
something very very smart
he said let's rotate every week the team
lead because when you are a team lead
you have a different perspective and not
always developers will know what's in
your head or will know what's what's it
like to be a team lead and when you
start rotating them first they start
understanding way more things and they
start understanding why such things are
like they are and then they have more
responsibility they're more involved
they find more meaning in the job they
do because this is what when you all are
on a leadership position it's quite
different so this yielded really good
results break in two minutes and I can
highly recommend it to give it a try
just rotate team leads again have
everything explicitly written down make
make it easy for someone to step in and
also this will how to say this will
improve the team with everyone's
perspective because sometimes when you
have a strong leader in a team he will
push his perspective and vision at the
end it will be mostly that but when you
rotate people on the team building
position then you're going to enrich
this team perspective and enrich this
vision with everyone's vision and
everyone will feel way more way more
involved inside the team again I can
highly recommend this and we'll finish
with conflicts but not merge conflicts
but rather human conflicts this is
something unavoidable at least in my
opinion if if there is a team without
conflict then there's just a conflict
waiting for for a proper time to surface
and it's really important how you're
going to handle the conflict over
communication seems like a really really
good general recommendation because
oftentimes conflicts come from people
not communicating enough between each
other having expectations for someone
else having expectations for example
person a has a specific expectations for
person B and person B does not meet
those expectations there's already a
conflict you know so it's really
important to lay down expectations to
over communicate there will be people
that will work it's going to be hard for
them to work together and you have to
identify this and depending on your
structure sometimes it's good to make
them work together more so they can
start playing well with each other or
sometimes it's good at you to not make
them work together for a while until
they figure out different things that
they need to solve for them you know and
I cannot give good recommendations here
because it's a hard topic but like read
books and management read books on
leadership it helps a lot practice it
that for example rotation on the team
leading position is a very good practice
for every once you have this leadership
capacity in themselves and there's those
two things you know there's all there
are there are always toxic people that
no matter what they will be toxic and
they kind of enjoy chaos anarchy and
bringing things down you have to
identify this sometimes it's fixable
sometimes it's not fixable you know then
you have to let them go there are people
on the other side of the spectrum
there's something called malicious
billions where they do exactly what
they've been taught and they don't think
you know they're kind of dependent on
you and it's like you're telling them
step by step like a computer program
what to do and they do exactly this and
nothing else which is also not a desired
trait inside of a team so you have to
learn to identify those things and
somehow work
fix them and firing is really hard
easier said than done it's really really
really really really hard because when
you have to fire someone the first at
least forbid the first thought is well
it's my responsibility that this person
is not fitting well I have not done
enough things and it's usually the case
but you have to kind of see where the
line is and you say I've given enough
opportunities it's not working let's see
what we can do about it
and of course finally adapt if you have
processes and you follow them blindly
people will learn to play the game and
will be again unproductive and
uneffective you know this humans are
really good at adapting and they adapt
they learn to play the game so you have
to make sure those at least for me those
seven traits for a team are always met
or are we are doing something about them
because if you say all right I've
invested a week here are the processes
this is the framework done I have no
longer I don't have the need to touch it
just follow the process blindly this is
not working you know things are changing
people are changing circumstances are
different so you need to adapt you need
to not constantly but often perhaps once
a month revisit everything check if
everyone's happy check what's happening
you know be friends with your with your
team and adapt everything and perhaps
the takeaway ask your developers for
pain points and they will tell you
because if you think there are no pain
points in your team you're just ignoring
the problem just ask them what are the
pain problems write them down discuss
them some of them are not fixable some
of them may be this is part of your job
and you have to learn to do it and some
of them are fixable easily fixable some
of them will require more work but it's
kind of the process of thinking about
your team and thinking about the world
think of your team and trying to do
things to improve the well-being of your
team if you have good intentions and
this will yield good results I think at
least this this is how we see things
that are at our company so thank you
this was it for me questions